sebastien you've mentioned before that
you had a love affair with risk where
does this currently stand
well I risk is still a very appealing
thing for a lot of people it seems to it
seems to increase your appreciation of
the moment and of life in general and it
enhances a lot of things but it also
occasionally comes at a cost and for me
that cost caught up with me in 2011 when
my good friend Tim Hetherington was
killed in Libya in combat he was killed
on an assignment that I was supposed to
be on with him the last minute I
couldn't go and he died and I was left
feeling tremendously guilty and also
keenly aware of the fact that when you
risk your life in war or anywhere else
it feels like you're just risking
something of yours your own life and
actually what you're putting at risk is
the emotional welfare of everyone you
love and I watched the the consequences
of Tim's death ripple out through his
community in the most devastating ways
and I just thought whatever the upside
of risk is personally it's not worth the
potential downside to everyone I care
about and I I mean literally within an
hour of finding out the timid died I
decided to stop covering war
you